[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  maybe you don't win this fight  maybe I don't need this fight yeah  because you know I know yeah I know  because you say I know you know because  I know you know you know I know yeah  that's why you got it you know I got a  you know maybe you don't win this fight  maybe I don't win this fight yeah  because you know I know you know I know  because you say I know you know because  I know you know someone on the line  thank you there's no dial tone  we're on the phone scampi hang up the  phone  scampi  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  I can have that in my head for scampi  hang up the phone  I'll be yelling at in my car on the way  home